Blend Spaces are assets that allow you to blend animations based on one or more values
like speed or direction, for example.
And Blend Spaces, they're more of a game design concept and were designed to reduce
the amount of animation assets necessary for the unpredictability of dynamic gameplay.
So again, Blend Spaces, they use one or more float values to determine how much influence
an animation has in the final blended motion.
And I'm just going to rebuild the current default Blend Space behavior that's in the engine.
So if I hit play, I've got my cardboard man and as I drive around, he transitions from
the idle to the running animation based on the speed.
So let's create a new Blend Space.
You can make a one dimensional Blend Space or a two dimensional Blend Space, which is the default.
And you can make a Blend Space from a skeletal mesh or a skeleton, actually.
I could right click on our cardboard retargeted man and I could go to create Blend Space 1D.
Or if you can't remember which skeleton the skeletal mesh is using, you could go to
skeleton, find skeleton, and then it zips us to our mannequin skeleton.
So since we're here, I'll just right click on the skeleton, create Blend Space 1D and
I'll call it BS demo idle one.
So I will open that up and dock the tab.
And we're looking at our new interface.
So let's drop in some animations and adjust the horizontal axis.
So if I go back to our Blend Space, let's change the name of the horizontal access to
speed and change the maximum value to 375, which is what the engine uses.
And I'm going to keep the number of grid divisions to four, but if you need more slots
for animations, feel free to increase that in the future.
And then there's not much to see right now, but you can preview by dragging the green diamond.
But to make things more interesting, if I want to add a run animation, all I have to
do is go to the asset browser and then just click drag third person run and a diamond
will appear depending on which line I'm closest to with the mouse.
So I'll just go to the far right and release.
And now Manny is running.
And if you did not see the asset browser, you can go to window and you should be able
to find asset browser right there.
And then I also want my character to idle when it's not in motion.
So I will drag third person idle all the way to the left and release.
And if you don't want to click drag the little diamond, if you hit the shift button on your
keyboard, you can release the mouse and all you have to do is move your mouse.
You don't have to click.
So we are idling and now we're running.
Ta-da!
Okay.
And then one more, let's add the walk.
Third person walk, I'll drag that to the line that's second from the left.
And if you ever decide to change the animation, all you have to do is just drag a new animation
on top of that diamond and then it will swap it out.
And if you need to reduce the number of transitions, you could just click a diamond, hit the delete
key on your keyboard.
But I want to put the walk animation back.
All right, let's hit save.
And we could also choose to make a 2D blend space.
And you'll notice that instead of just having a horizontal axis, there's also a vertical
axis.
So you could have both speed and direction or you don't have to be limited to those examples.
And the complexity, it increases as you can see.
And without this system, I mean, imagine having an individual animation represented for each
of these different combinations.
So it's nice that you don't have to do that.
That's a brief introduction to blend spaces.
And in the next video, we will work on the crowd simulation.